isn't it kind of crazy though that you
had a short or a couple shorts that
you've done and then here you've taken
this big leap where you're writing
directing or co directing producing and
then you're the protagonist for in a
feature like how does that happen that
it's that's all that's area it was it
again I shot the film when I was thirty
right so it took a long time to get to
that point wasn't overnight you know I
had it I had done a lot of short films
my whole life growing up with my
friend's family in college done a lot of
training as an actor really learned how
to write well took a year and a half
studying videos from great YouTube
channels on how to tell good story
through film how to direct how to direct
a film how light how learning what
cameras are and and you know f-stops and
all this stuff I took a year and a half
to learn all that because I didn't go to
film school right
that would YouTube was my film school
you guys were part of my film school
right so it it wasn't crazy because it
was the right time it was it was rat was
ready for it
it would have been crazy having to try
this when I was twenty do that woman
crazy but it was just I was just ready
for it you know I I was done with shorts
I was done with five five minutes shorts
I was done with 15 minutes course I was
just ready to make a big one and in it
like I said it was just all fell into
place really did it what I wasn't scared
I was nervous I was excited you know
looking back in hindsight you know
having finished the feature and writing
the words the end that was an amazing
experience amazing feeling but B just
just you don't run before you can walk
and take the time to prepare yourself
and practice you know I I was very
strict growing up when I was riding my
shorts and doing my shorts I was writing
five page shorts and I was writing I was
practicing how to write full story out
of five pages religiously sticking to
five pages giving myself a five page
budget
and then advancing cake now I'm going to
do ten pages and that was that and I
never did anything more than that but I
got really used to writing to a page
budget so when I had to write 90 pages I
got it to 90 pages you know so like I
said it wasn't crazy because I was
prepared
I watched a movie last year documentary
free solo and in an interview with Alex
Hamlin he he said they were asked how
much adrenaline are you feeling off up
there he goes why I wasn't feeling any
adrenaline adrenaline is when things go
wrong
I was calm OHS collected I was ready for
this there's this experience and I
totally agree with that I had I felt
nervous or unprepared then I think it
would have been crazy but I was ready I
was ready for it so you finished the
film you finished editing and then now
you have this movie what are you doing
with it okay so it's never as easy as
it's not as easy as I thought it was
gonna be as far as the editing is done
it's done because we shot on a
professional cinema camera right so
there's a lot that goes into editing raw
footage right so then it's like okay
time to color the film can I learn how
to color a film so I did need to learn
how to compose music I can't do that so
I got to find people who can so it it
took a long time to took about a year a
year to finish the film at that point
when it's all completed we we talked to
my producer we say how we gonna
distribute this thing how we gonna get
people's eyeballs on it right obviously
the most popular out is the film
festival route which I was never
interested in actually I I talked to all
my team before and I said hey we're just
probably gonna go VOD just leave it at
that I'm not really interested in
festivals they say that's fine
but then I decided that festivals offer
eyeballs people to see so we submit it
to lots of festivals and we are
continuing to submit to AUSA festivals
now that it's fully completed and still
having to get to hear back from things
we recently got into the new filmmakers
festival here in LA that's very exciting
so we they every month they premiere a
feature and then a bunch of
and we are the future for next month yes
super exciting
so yeah June 29th and we're really
excited about that nice which where is
it located down downtown LA I think it's
called the South Park Center I mean in
downtown LA and they host film they host
film festival every month it's so cool
because it's going off for a year or
something cool it's all new new budding
filmmakers people who are just getting
their start in the industry it's awesome
so it's a really good resource a really
good Film Festival to look into for
young young new filmmakers but again
submitting to all the big festivals
I never was hoping for distribution
through those festivals I was just
hoping for people to see the film but
mostly VOD Amazon Prime is amazing
because Amazon video direct as long as
you have the right technical specs for
your camera for it for your film the
right closed captions and two pieces of
art you can upload video direct and then
you can have your video on Amazon Prime
tomorrow and then it's all about you
know the promotions which is crazy so
after after we see how these festivals
kind of run if we get into them or not
then we'll just go straight back to
Amazon Prime and we're in the talks
currently with one of the pr end of it
an individual with PR for netflix and
she's kind of helping us develop our
press packets and everything for that so
we can develop buzz around it and then
we're gonna set up I'll press screenings
and try to just get as many eyeballs on
the phone as possible but it is
definitely self distributing for sure do
you know what the specs are for a video
direct yeah so closed captions are
absolute must I would say follow Netflix
is standard for closed captions Netflix
has a really specific standard Amazon
doesn't have a specific standard but if
you follow a Netflix is standard it kind
of covers the across the board everyone
all the VOD sites I think they have the
best standard you can look it up online
it's right there that's what we did we
followed their standards to a tee I mean
it's as specific as no less that your
your caption can't be less than 20 20
frames you have to have a minimum of two
frames separating each caption oh you
can't don't separate your your phrases
at adjectives or things like that and
it's very specific but just follow those
guidelines and then you'd be really good
Amazon I'll take them to pieces of art
you have to have your a poster and then
another poster that in different sizes
they have their sytem I'm not familiar
with the sizes right now but they have
their sizes on their site build those
posters really easy upload the two
pieces of art and then you'll have those
set to go and then upload your film and
your film I I don't think I think
they've gotten tighter recently I can't
speak for Amazon specifically but
because I knew we shot on the cinema
camera with all professional sound and
everything I knew we would be okay I
think back in the past they would like
just allow Home Video kind of stuff I
don't know if they do that anymore but
they will review it and then within for
two to four business days it'll be up
live on Amazon Prime and you have enough
film on Amazon Prime for everyone to see
right now and and then I think that's
really really solid because then you can
use that you know hey Hulu we're talking
to we've brought Amazon Prime you can
check it out right now
Netflix when Amazon Prime you can check
it out right now most importantly press
hey you can check out our film on Amazon
Prime right now and it's got some clout
Amazon's got clout and they have an
officer they have an Oscar so yeah so
it's a really really great place to host
your film in the beginning while you're
still trying to generate buzz
you